hi i'm steve clemons and i have a
question as the war in ukraine gets
uglier will the massive global sanctions
now imposed against russia and many
russian oligarchs and vladimir putin
himself work let's get to the bottom
line
in response to the russian attack on
ukraine the u.s and its allies have
chosen to punish it in part with
financial weapons the plan and theory at
least is to cut the russian government
from its hundreds of billions of dollars
in reserves and shut it out of the
global financial system sanctions aren't
a new form of warfare the us has been
targeting iran venezuela north korea and
cuba for decades russia itself has been
living with lower level american
sanctions since 2014 when it annexed the
crimean peninsula from ukraine but
russia produces huge amounts of gas and
wheat and other global commodities which
give it some leverage and russian gas is
not affected by the sanctions right now
but at least one senator joe manchin of
west virginia has said it's time to
unleash the real economic atomic bomb
which is boycotting russia fuel imports
to the united states so can sanctions
actually force russia to change course
or do they just make life miserable for
the average russian citizen while the
government finds other ways to fund
itself are sanctions just a way to fake
action when there are a few other
options to stop a power play from
happening today we're talking with lee
jones professor of political economy and
international relations at the
university of london he's the author of
societies under siege exploring how
international economic sanctions in
parentheses do not work and then david
asher a senior fellow at the hudson
institute here in washington dc who's
been an advisor to the u.s government on
sanctions evasion including economic
warfare campaign strategies against the
islamic state hezbollah in lebanon and
iran david let me start with you
when have sanctions work what are the
characteristics of making sanctions
uh particularly in a case as we're
looking at russia right now but but
looking at other historic cases
you know steve they've they've worked
effectively when they're part of a
campaign of a broader policy
uh to disrupt or or
affect or even deter
a state or society or
transnational organization a terrorist
organization drug cartel for example
um
ronald reagan had uh
economic war campaign that he founded in
the in the form of a
national security council document in
1982 that became
the center of a massive effort by the
u.s government to disrupt the soviet
economy no one seems to remember
how much of an impact it had but it was
absolutely central to
the fall of the berlin wall and the
change in the soviet government uh
toward modern day russia which of course
has now turned back toward the soviet
union
we it we would be wise to remember how
it worked and what it accomplished and
to try to
revive certain aspects of it because
these
the goal there was
to make life difficult for the
leadership to disrupt their their center
of gravity their thinking
it wasn't just it wasn't to hurt the
russian people
the most detrimental action that we took
of course if you've read the
unclassified or now declassified
documents was
the explosion of the russian far east
pipeline the pipeline the very pipeline
that is today feeding
gas into western europe i'm not
advocating that but in 1982 and 83 that
was the option it hadn't been completed
it wasn't yet connected to europe and
the red administration saw the value of
making that disconnection
palpable so you know sanctions was that
was not a sanction that was an action uh
sanctions work uh
in the best form when they're combined
with the varieties of a variety of overt
and covert actions um i think right now
an issue i have is we just have a
sanctions policy
uh we don't really have a broader policy
yet we're starting to
thanks to the reaction to
the tyranny
and the oppressiveness of what's going
on in ukraine do you think vladimir
putin
has a price do you think his cronies the
oligarchs around him have a price that
deterring them freezing their assets uh
collapsing the asset values around them
matters to these people there is a price
in my mind toward putin's reputation and
his mojo you got to look at him like
tony soprano the famous uh
mob boss from the tv series um you gotta
look at john gotti i was involved going
after a guy named john gotti he was a
major you were you were you helped go
after john goddard i was involved yeah i
went off the gambino crime family writ
large um
and i went after the sinaloa drug cartel
under chapel guzman and we had a similar
sort of theory of operation
uh we had a concept that
we could create a situation where they
weren't
able to
basically tend to the needs of their
inner sanctum
we complicated their their command
control communications
their reliability and their
dependability as bosses
and it's called value-based targeting i
did the very same approach toward uh
kim jong-il in in north korea the
previous leader
i i was after going
all the going after all the things that
really mattered to him we came up with a
very detailed assessment
uh in 2002 of what mattered to keep him
alive as a leader and we attacked every
one of them and that worked quite well
until the administration decided i was
too successful and they said you know
the war in iraq that i was going to
create a regime change in north korea
which is what i've been ordered to do
but uh
you know not non-kinetically but the
point is i think there is a there is a
way to affect vladimir putin it's not
just money though it's a lot there are a
lot of things that need to be attacked
beyond money and so sanctions are just a
piece well lee jones um i really
appreciate you joining us from london
you've written a very interesting paper
saying sanctions won't save ukraine and
the sub headline is they are a
comforting illusion in a leaderless war
you know give us you know your
understanding of sanctions policy where
they've worked where they haven't worked
i think what you've just heard is right
this the academic evidence does suggest
that sanctions alone
are not very successful they work only
about five percent of the time
when they're just deployed on their own
and when they're deployed alongside
other measures a general consensus in
the academic research is that they work
about a thirty percent of the time so
they still fail about two thirds of the
time
and i think one of the reasons why they
fail so often i mean there are many
reasons i think one of the key ones
is the issue you've just been discussing
about whether
there is a price
so there is an underlying logic to
sanctions that if i can manipulate your
cost benefit analysis
if i can create additional costs for you
then you will revise your cost benefit
analysis and rationally choose to change
your behavior
and what we've just heard is that
that works against drugs cartels so the
logic is well it should also work
against political leaders the difficulty
is that i think political leaders are
not like um
drugs cartels they're not business their
primary goal is not to make money
they have a whole host of other
objectives and goals
which are not necessarily convertible to
dollars and cents pounds and pence and
so on so it becomes quite difficult i
think to say okay let's just you know
rapture up the costs just a little bit
more
and then we'll be able to tweak their
cost-benefit analysis
because i think what what we've seen in
history
is many regimes are willing to endure
really quite colossal
economic costs
in order to prioritize securing their
political and security goals so if you
take the the case of north korea that's
just been mentioned and sanctions
against north korea have not been
successful in the sense that
the north korean regime has been willing
to endure isolation
reputational damage
poverty among its own population and so
on in order to secure nuclear weapons
which it believes are essential to the
preservation of the regime's own
security against
the threat of the united states
we saw that also in iraq the path party
regime understand insane was willing to
forego certain objectives so it was
willing despite what we were told in
2003 to disarm it it's um weapons of
mass destruction it was willing to
withdraw from from kuwait and issue rep
reparations and so on but it was not
willing to just abandon power it was it
would rather see
fractions in the in the regime would
rather see the criminalization of the
state the impoverishment of the
population before it would
uh relinquish power and it took troops
to
finish off the regime
so
when it comes to vladimir putin what we
have to ask is
he primarily motivated by
his own pecuniary interests right his
private yachts his bank balance
and i'll do the oligarchs around him you
know primarily interested in that and
are the
you know 70 plus of people who vote for
him
are they motivated really by that or
primarily by that or are they going to
prioritize these other political and
security goals above their peculiar
interests and if they do that
then they can pretend potentially be
quite severe economic suffering on the
russian side without it leading to the
outcome that we want
so we have to be able to tell a
plausible story when we impose sanctions
what is the plausible link
between imposing economic pain
and the political gain that we seek and
is there a plausible causal story we can
tell if there isn't then there's the
risk that we just impose hardship
without getting what we want david what
is your reaction to that because i i
agree i mean
and people don't understand the
sanctions i've never approached
sanctions like this on off right
uh button or a faucet you just turn on
and off the hot and cold water
it's never been my approach my approach
has always been not coercive diplomacy
as they call it or statecraft my
approach has been absolute pressure
containment destruction deterrence
and disruption it's not about playing
soft
power games which i'm afraid is how like
we're right now
you know i i i know and you know and
he's a brilliant young fellow uh not too
young anymore but uh
his view i think is that this is uh
something you use to modulate a behavior
i have no doubt that it will not
modulate behavior if anything we're
doing right now is probably going to
accelerate putin's decision-making cycle
now that might be useful though because
he's building his own quagmire okay so
but that's probably not what they're
doing okay what i'd be doing is i would
be
doing things to affect his
sanctity his inner sanctum his peace of
mind i'd be using economic warfare as a
part of warfare you know when i went
after the islamic state when i led the
islamic specificity about his campaign
you know with general mcfarland as our
combatant commander
sean and i went to war against their
finances and we literally bombed the
central bank in mosul where their money
was blew up billion to two billion i
think it was about two billion dollars
in cash baghdadi cried okay and yeah i
think i'll share with your affair
you know viewers will respect that i
mean we literally you know picked him up
on the radio and he was screaming in in
horror because we just blew up his money
i mean it was not about um trying to
change his decision-making process his
decision-making process like putin's was
set
we had to destroy his his his uh mojo i
guess you want to call it well let me
ask you about that's part of the mojo
david because part of it is you know
i've seen oleg derapaska for our
audience oleg garposka is a major global
aluminum tycoon michael friedman who is
the chairman of alpha bank and and the
ceo of letter one uh living in london uh
a ukrainian russian has come out
strongly critical of this war and
conflict and so it begins to raise the
question of whether or not the pressure
that's being created around some of the
people around putin begin to create a
dynamic
that changes history i think it can but
i don't think it's gonna change putin's
view yeah i think it's gonna lead to uh
potential alternatives to putin in the
future
uh i mean you've really got to think
ahead
when reagan imposed his pressure
strategy which was well beyond sanctions
we did have sanctions but they had been
long-standing against russia in 1982
um it was about bringing down the berlin
wall i mean literally this the berlin
famous berlin wall bringing down the
wall speech was all linked
to the national security policy
decisions that were surrounding the
economic warfare campaign against the
soviet union we
gave money to solidarity to rise up in
poland we gave
money inside russia to scientists who
were uh refuse nicks and and who who
came right to rebel against uh the the
soviet system and and we we encourage
massive defections including some of the
smartest people in the country who were
related to their economic system if you
look back on some of the things i was
involved with in north korea you'll see
some of the same hallmarks i mean you
know a lot of smart people left
and the others were killed and i'm not
saying i killed them but they just died
as part of the process this was a really
tough approach it's not nice
um
you know we it's it's not uh you know
we're gonna turn the sanction on and off
we're creating permanent conditions to
break or bend
or you know undermine a regime and
that's what we should do if we're going
to go to economic ward putin we need to
understand its economic war i'm afraid
right now we're between these sanctions
like we have all the cards and they have
none they have a huge ability to counter
attack and we haven't seen it yet i'm a
little surprised i think putin's been a
little awkward
but we're going to probably see huge
cyber attacks against our financial
system and you know i don't know if
americans are prepared to lose a
thousand points in the stock market you
know in the nasdaq really important
point i want to throw back to lee jones
is do we
do do
uh uh citizens in the uk have a price do
american citizens have a price uh in
this in this process as well i mean you
you said something very important that i
i have already heard reports about uh
malicious malware uh having impacts both
in europe and the united states because
when you launch malware into this system
it can have an it whether it was you
know consciously targeted at at the u.s
or not but there there are these
questions which i think lee jones got
right which is which is the price that
those that are trying to defend against
aggression are willing to pay or whether
they're willing to acquiesce your
thoughts lee
no i think you're right
i mean it's really interesting listening
to what david's saying because i think
that's quite a different view of
sanctions to i think the mainstream of
of policy making certainly in europe i
don't think that there's
much desire or or will on the part of
most of the nato powers and perhaps not
also the united states to combine
sanctions with the much wider suites of
coercion coercive measures i mean it's
not possible to physically bomb the
the russian central bank for example you
know we are a very dangerous point if
we're heading into a confrontation with
a nuclear armed power and i think that
there hasn't been
very much uh clear strategic thinking
about in heading into this crisis
because the russians have made their
position very clear
which is that they're not willing to
tolerate the
emergence of nato states on their
borders and they've invaded
georgia in 2008 and ukraine in 2014 to
illustrate how serious they are
and i think
nato's position the eu and position has
been fundamentally quite ambiguous on
the one hand they've not said will
protect ukraine on the other hand they
haven't said that you won't protect
ukraine they've sort of
an ambiguous position
which has kind of emboldened the
ukrainian government to say that we're
going to join nato we're going to join
the eu and further antagonize russia so
on the one hand they haven't
accommodated russian security interests
but they haven't done enough to fully
deter russia either and so there's been
a sort of lack of clear strategic
thinking here it's it's a real strategic
blunder on the west part i think and
then when it comes to sanctions you know
suddenly the population in certainly in
in
europe i think it's fair to say i'm not
so sure about the united states but i
suppose it may be true there too
it's the first time that we've really
thought about but what does it really
mean to engage in a in a really serious
confrontation with with russia um
are we really going to go to war for
ukraine i mean the governments here are
very clear that's not going to happen
now when push comes to shove are we
willing to go to economic war with
russia i think that's also a really hard
sell for populations because the big way
that you can really damage you know
cause the kind of wreckage and carnage
that dave is talking about
the way that you could do that with
russia is to sanction their energy
exports it counts for nearly 60 percent
of their their exports when you add up
oil
gas and coal but europe is heavily
dependent on imports of oil and gas from
russia let me david let me jump to you
and ask you um do we understand where
the consequences should go as sanctions
are bandied about as a tool which both
of you have said and can have dramatic
impacts not just on the leader or maybe
not even on the leader but on society as
a whole i mean look yeah
i'm an economic historian and a proud
one there not many of us in the world um
a graduate of oxford
where i did my doctorate and um
i have studied the blowback from
sanctions as well i'm not disagreeing
with lee entirely at all i mean people
people don't quite they think of me as
mr sanctions and i've been involved in
sanctioning a huge number of entities in
my career probably more than anyone
in the u.s government except well
probably more than juan zarate actually
because i've been around through
democrat and republican government so
i've not just been
partisan
and
there is a cost
that can occur in blowback you can you
can also you blow up yourself in this
process of sanctions you know when we
sanctions to the japanese in 1939 1940
uh their oil uh
enterprises and their oil are our oil
exports to them and then from southeast
asia
it led them to attack pearl harbor okay
there's no doubt about that uh when when
we went after milosevic
in 98 it was a very clear concept for
operations which was in a matrix it
literally is called operation matrix we
had all these different
uh attack vectors we went after the
people that uh that were against them
and we built up the people that actually
went after the people that were
supporting him and we uh helped the
people that were against them i mean you
know we played both sides
built one side up against the other and
then we attacked his finances and
literally went to cyprus in 1998 and i
think was in the spring as i recall and
told the cypriots that they have 3.3
billion dollars in milosevic's money and
either they freeze freeze it and cut him
off at the knees or we were going to cut
off cyprus and you know what the
slippery government did without having
even a legal basis they'd cut off
milosevic and you know about six weeks
later as i recall he fell from power he
came in he really walked in okay so
there is a history of course of
sanctions working coercive sanctions
though is different than course of
diplomacy right this whole idea that you
can just use them as a diplomatic tool
i've rejected that i've used them as a
type of containment tool as a deterrent
tool um but not really for a negotiation
you don't like you know raise the costs
on a gangster so that he quits being a
gangster it's just not going to work
that way what you can do is you can
raise the cost on his survival
so that
opposing forces come to bear i mean it's
you know i i when i go to economic war
with an adversary i go to war i don't
play around
uh lee i'd love to get you in our in our
final minutes to share with us if you
were to correct those
mistakes and to create a more
efficacious sanctions regime that could
have traction in a case like we're
seeing in ukraine what would be the
elements of that uh that you would
suggest
i think you have to start always with an
analysis of the target society because
you could take
sanctions that succeeded ostensibly in
one case and copy them
in a word for word dollar for dollar to
another case and it would have a
completely different outcome because the
political economy of that target society
and the political dynamics in that
society are completely different
so people often talk about south africa
and say well you know sanctions worked
there so they can work in case x right
but that's not obviously not the case
south africa had a very unique set of
circumstances that allowed sanctions to
play some kind of role
so we have to look at a target like
russia and say okay
let's assume that we're able to design
sanctions that can impose serious
economic harm in russia without ideally
blowing ourselves up as david says
which is quite hard given how dependent
we've become on russian um commodity
exports but even if you could
what's the logic
how is this going to change things in
russia is it going to
split the putin regime are they is it
going to prompt defections from the
regime from the military
are the oligarchs gonna always oust him
is any of this remotely plausible
and it seems to me and i'm not a
russianist so i should emphasize that
um it seems to me that
putin is highly popular he enjoyed the
popularity rating of 69 percent last
time he invaded ukraine his popularity
rating increased by 20
right it looks to me like the elite
seemed fairly united behind him you know
400 to one vote in the dubai and phase
of recognizing the breakaway republics
um that he was able to dress down his uh
spy chief on live uh television for
bluffing his lines at the um right at
the stage managed security council
meeting it does not appear to me i say
as a non-specialist that there are many
elite fractures
that sanctions could exploit in the
short term
and that's the causal story that we need
to be able to tell
right is it possible that by inflicting
economic pain we're going to get the
political gain that we want
and if not then potentially we create in
a very widespread suffering but uh
without getting what we know i want to
thank very much university of london
professor lee jones and hudson institute
senior fellow some people call him mr
sanctions david asher uh thank you both
for being with us today this was
terrific thank you
pleasure thank you
so what's the bottom line
there's always a debate about the nature
of power is it military force or is it
economic strength the debate about
sanctions is similar are they useful or
not useful to some
sanctioning russian president vladimir
putin who's launched a war against a
neighboring country is pathetically weak
but as mr sanctions himself said today
there could be power in targeting
players who violate core international
stability and acceptable codes of
conduct other countries will try to
expose freeze and erase the personal
assets of these rulers and their cronies
who use power to get rich or use their
riches to get power but as lee jones
reminds sanctions don't always have a
good track record as a tool to change
the behavior of governments ten years
ago i would have agreed and said
sanctions are feckless now i believe
they are an essential weapon and the
arsenal pointed at the world's most
reckless and that's the bottom line
[Music]
you